the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back from my breakdown of the a season a
game of Thrones in my last video I
talked about some of the big events I
think we could see in the opening
episode of the final season today I want
to continue by discussing some of the
events that may or may not happen in the
second episode of the a season a Game of
Thrones the opening scene of the opening
episode is reported to open up a
Winterfell with what could be the
arrival of Jon Snow and Daenerys
Targaryen so with that in mind I think
they could open up the second episode in
a different location in my last video I
said I wasn't quite sure which episode
you're on Greyjoy would return what the
golden company we do know that he
already went to retrieve them in the
season 7 finale after he left the parler
scene at the dragon pit since the
television show has been moving at an
incredible pace he very well could show
up with the golden company in the first
episode but I'm gonna go ahead and say
he doesn't arrive until the second
episode and here's why
since we're gonna have that big opening
scene at Winterfell with everyone
arriving in the first episode I think
they could do something very similar in
the second episode but this time it
could be you're on along with the golden
company and the relevance arriving in
King's Landing to meet with Cersei
Lannister once they arrive I imagine
that Cersei would want to speak with the
commander of the golden company right
away
the first thing she might try to do is
make sure the guy knows who is actually
in charge then of course she needs to
inform him of her plans does Cersei
intend on keeping them in King's Landing
to protect the capital or does she want
to go on the offensive by sending them
to the north to attack Jonathan Ayers
from behind when they are simultaneously
trying to fight the night king's army if
Cersei sent them to the north right away
that could deliver a devastating blow to
John and Danny's forces but she would
also run the risk of getting all of her
men killed in the process I'm gonna say
Cersei will keep the majority of her men
close by to protect the city otherwise
King's Landing would be extremely
vulnerable if she only had to city watch
to rely on you have to keep in mind
without your on in the golden company
Cersei doesn't have many
men laughed at our disposal most of her
lannister and Tarly forces were killed
by Daenerys drogon in our army of
Dothraki screamers I can't imagine that
Cersei would have too many Lannister
soldiers left so it might be in our best
interest to keep the golden company in
King's Landing while she waits to attack
whatever men John and Daenerys have left
after they get done fighting the army of
the dead by then
it could be a very close to an even
matchup depending on how many soldiers
John and Daenerys lose against the night
king and of course there is always a
chance that Daenerys could lose more
dragons when fighting the night King as
well Cersei could potentially keep all
of her soldiers healthy and fresh while
John and Daenerys get most of their men
killed and or injured let's just say
that by the time John and Daenerys are
ready to head back down to King's
Landing to deal with Cersei they could
be running very low on gas when that
time comes when in the meantime
Cersei was making her force even bigger
also there is always that possibility
that Cersei could have more wildfire and
ballistas made at the same time this
could make for one very interesting
battle for King's Landing near the end
of the season which I know I can't wait
to see when it comes to Cersei Lannister
soldiers there is one other thing I want
to mention before I go any further in my
opinion I think there is a very good
chance that Jaime Lannister could get
some of those men to leave with him as
we all know Jaime less Cersei at the end
of last season the final shot of Jamie
was him sitting on the horse alone with
King's Landing right over his shoulder
but we all know it would be extremely
dangerous for Jaime to travel all the
way to Winterfell alone this is another
one of the reasons why I think we could
see Jaime meet up with Bronn and we
could see him gather up as many troops
as possible before he begins that long
journey to the north to fight the army
of the dead now if you remember right as
Jaime and Cersei were about to have
their last conversation together we saw
Jaime advising some of the top
lieutenants or captains of the Lannister
army Cersei walked in as Jaime was
telling his men they needed to go to
Winterfell to help Jon and Daenerys
so after Jaime walked out on Cersei he
could have paid those men 'visit and
told them what was happening
although Cersei might be their queen
Jaime is their commander so they might
be willing to follow Jaime no matter
what Jaime could have also went to them
and not even told them that he had a
falling out with Cersei he could have
just said something like hey it's time
to go north don't ask questions just get
your [ __ ] and let's
go since Jamie Lannister is the
commander they have to listen to him
however if Cersei was smart as soon as
Jamie walked out on her she should have
immediately sent out word to all of
their Bannerman saying that Jamie is a
traitor and anyone that gets caught with
him will also be branded as a traitor a
crime which is punishable by death but
as I'm sure most of you know I like
Jamie more than I like Cersei so I'm
hoping things can work out in his favor
at least to some extent if Jamie could
show up in Winterfell with at least a
small force that could put him in a much
better position even though Jon and
Daenerys already agreed to fight
together with him against the night king
we all know Jamie will face some
problems when he arrives but if he's
able to show up with an army he can at
least say hey you might not like me but
you know damn well you need my men so we
might not have seen Jamie pay anyone a
visit before he left the city but that
does not mean he did not speak to many
people before he left
Jamie could have even sent out some
Ravens before he left that way whoever
is maintaining Riverrun of the twins
will be expecting him to show up Cersei
could be in for a big surprise when she
goes to call upon the Lannister troops
they might have already left to me Jamie
somewhere along the road to Winterfell
just keep that in the back of your mind
because I will not be surprised if
something like that happens now let's
move on to your on Greyjoy as of right
now I would say that your on is in a
very good position when it comes to
negotiating with Cersei not only has he
been a man of his word ever since they
formed their alliance but he has went
above and beyond for Cersei on multiple
occasions at this point now that Jaime
has gone and out of the way Euron might
actually have some leverage let's face
it
Cersei needs your on Anna's fleets
Cersei cannot run the risk of losing any
more men at this point so she might find
herself in a position to where she needs
to start meeting some of Euron's demands
keep in mind that the representative
from the iron bank
Tycho's he more or less said the same
thing to Cersei during their last
meeting Euron Greyjoy might be loyal for
now but that doesn't mean that he's
gonna be loyal forever my Ahmad and the
Narrow Sea
Yulin Greyjoy some others there's angry
joe is loyal to me now those words had
to stick with Cersei and there are
something else she needs to keep in mind
since you're on is picking up the golden
company she
has to know that that means you're on is
gonna spend an awful lot of time with
these men and their commander now Cersei
might be the person that is putting the
money inside of their pockets but Euron
can be very charming and very cunning at
the same time when traveling with these
men at sea he could form a bond with
their commander therefore Cersei might
want to be careful before she starts
demanding you're on to go and do this or
go and do that without giving him
anything in return the next time he goes
to leave he could try to get all of
those men to load right back up onto his
ships and take them with him at least
that's what I would be thinking if I
were Cersei now I say all that to say
this do not be surprised if we see
Cersei and Euron have sex in this
episode or any other episode next season
based on some of the off season reports
we know Cersei gets naked next season
now we don't know why she needs her nude
body double but there can only be a few
reasons why they would we won't be
seeing any more walk of atonement for
Cersei Lannister and we won't be seeing
any more sex scenes with Jaime Lannister
so my guess is Cersei either gets naked
for some reason due to her alleged
pregnancy or she bangs euron greyjoy now
as I said in my last video I expect
Cersei and Qyburn to mass-produce
ballistas and wildfire so we could get
an update on their status in this
episode Cersei could have the golden
company begin to station the ballistas
all around the city while Cersei and
Euron go down into the dungeons to check
on the progress of the wildfire that
would let us know that Jon and Daenerys
might have the bigger army but Cersei
isn't just sitting around on her ass
hoping that the night king does all of
her dirty work
this would let us know that Cersei has
taken care of bidness now let's get the
hell out of King's Landing and head
across the sea to volantis if we don't
see Melisandre and volantis in the very
first episode that I think we need to
see her in volantis near the very
beginning of the second episode for this
reason we know for a fact that the night
king and his army will reach Winterfell
by the third episode HBO even released
this information to Entertainment Weekly
just a few weeks ago but we pretty much
knew this what happened as soon as we
found out miguel support snake would be
directing the third and fifth episode we
also know that ever since Melisandre was
introduced in the show her main purpose
her main driving force has been to bring
the light to the darkness Melisandre has
always known that this day would come
and stop in the White Walkers has been
her main
motivation for most of her actions of
thus far everything has been building to
this moment ever since the White Walkers
were introduced in the opening scene of
the pilot episode so if you think
there's gonna be a Great War without
Melisandre being there you're out of
your damn mind
we rarely only need to see one scene
with Melisandre and volantis and at the
end of that scene I think she needs to
indicate that she has to leave right
away that way when she shows up in
Winterfell near the end of the third
episode it's not too hard to believe
that she could have made it there in
time afterwards we can assume that
Melisandre was traveling for most of the
second episode and most of the third
episode then she can show up to
hopefully shift the battle back in Jon
and Danny's favor remember this is a
Song of Ice and Fire ladies and
gentlemen the fate of the entire realm
hangs in the balance during the great
battle for Humanity everything that
represents ice and everything that
represents fire will be in attendance
during this battle Melisandre will not
only be there but she will play one of
the biggest parts when it comes to
defeating the night king I'll go more
into those details in the next video
when Melisandre actually arrives in
Winterfell but for now let's talk about
the reasons why Melisandre may have went
to volantis in the first place
I did make a video about this very
recently so I will try to keep it brief
in my opinion there are only a handful
of reasons why I think Melisandre would
have needed to go here but for the night
King arrives for those of you that don't
know volantis contains the largest red
temple over lore red temples are where a
red priests can conduct their devotions
every night lighting a fire and praying
throughout the entire night for real or
to bring back the dawn well do you
remember how big the septa baler was in
King's Landing the one that Cersei blew
up with wildfire this red temple in
volantis is three times the size of
acceptable or so you can only imagine
how many followers of the Lord of Light
warships at this temple on any given
night you can also imagine that this
temple has to be crawling with
high-ranking members over lore people
like Melisandre and can Varro
when Melisandre arrives in volantis I
assume that she will announce that she
has United Ice and Fire
meaning Jon and Daenerys then she will
remind everyone of the return of the
great other meaning the night king well
that time has finally come
so if anyone from whirl or truly wanted
to help in this effort
now would be the time to come to
Westeros
to stop the darkness by helping John and
Daenerys bring the dawn who Melisandre
brings back with her is a bit of a
mystery but I imagine it will be more
than just one person or artefact she
could potentially return with an army of
her own an army consisting of followers
of real or slave soldiers in high
ranking red priests and priestesses
Daenerys will not be the only person
that brings fire into the fold but now I
want to move on to Theon Greyjoy like I
said in my last video
Theon will most likely be heading to the
Iron Islands first Theon Greyjoy should
still be under the impression that
that's where you're on and Yara were
heading the reason for that is because
of what your own Greyjoy said during the
dragon pit scene at that meeting
Joran reminded Theon that he still had
his sister Yara then after the white was
released from the crate Euron did
announce that he was heading back to the
Iron Islands because of the whites could
not swim in the water now we all know
that he was lying because Cersei reveals
that he's actually picking up the golden
company for her but the only other
person that knows that information right
now is Jaime Lannister
after a Theon got into the fight on the
beach a dragon stone he set out to go
find his sister and at that time he
still had to be under the impression
that your home was going to the Iron
Islands like he said at the dragon pit
when Theon Greyjoy arrives at the Iron
Islands he's going to quickly realize
that something isn't quite right because
you're on and Yara will not be there
Theon travelled all that way for nothing
but it will ultimately help him in the
long run since you're on left the dragon
pit to pick up the golden company
immediately by the time Theon gets to
the Iron Islands
Euron should be on his way back to
King's Landing to drop off the golden
company that should actually benefit
Theon because it would give him an
opportunity to get aboard this islands
without too many men being on the ship
already you're on should be back in
King's Landing well before Theon gets
back around the coast once you're on in
the golden company do arrive in King's
Landing I imagine that you're on would
leave his fleet right out in the
Blackwater Bay as soon as they're in the
city
you're on in the commander of the golden
company will most likely be with Cersei
for the most part but the majority of
the other men will probably spread out
throughout the city so they can get the
hell off of those ships they will
probably want to go to some of the local
taverns to get a drink or stop at the
brothels this would give Theon the
perfect opportunity to strike Euron's
fleet would literally be like a bunch of
sitting ducks in
now I'm sure that your on when leaves
some of his men behind to watch over the
ships but nothing compared to what it
would be like if Theon came upon Euron's
fleet while he was sailing at full force
with your on his men in the golden
company spread throughout King's Landing
Theon may be able to get his sister back
without meeting too much resistance now
of course we will get a final
confrontation between Theon and Euron at
some point but I don't think that
happens just yet however I do think that
Theon could get his sister back if he
can sneak up on the silence at night you
know what would actually be pretty dope
if Beyond snuck onto the silence freed
his sister then set Euron's fleet on
fire before he leaves if Theon has time
to sneak on to the silence then he
should have enough time to set the damn
thing on fire as he's getting off of it
imagine if your on would look out of one
of the windows of the Red Keep and he
saw his entire fleet going up in flames
that would be hilarious but let's get
out of the south and head up to the
north all the way up to Castle black
by this time beric Dondarrion in tormund
Giantsbane should be reaching Castle
black now you have to remember they were
most likely stranded on top of the wall
after the night King completely
destroyed eastwatch-by-the-sea when the
night king knocked down that portion of
the wall American torment should have
had no other way of getting down unless
they walked along the top of the wall
until they reached another castle that
has some sort of steps or elevator
system in place since most of the
castles have been out of commission for
a very long time it's probably not safe
to get down anywhere else but Castle
black the length of the wall is roughly
300 miles long Castle black is located
pretty much directly in the centre of
the wall but that's almost 150 miles
away from East to watch by the sea since
Eastwatch was located right at the edge
of the wall therefore barrack and
torment would have had one hell of a
journey ahead of them just to reach
Castle black on foot if this is the case
and they had to walk to Castle black
then there is no other way they should
be showing up in the first episode but
if they showed up in the middle of the
second episode I suppose that would work
they do need to get there somewhat fast
because we need these men in Winterfell
by the time the night King arrives in
the third episode so I'm gonna go ahead
and say that they reach Castle black in
this episode and once they get there
they will immediately alert everyone of
what happened at eastwatch-by-the-sea
now that's assuming that bran
sansa didn't already send out word via
Ravens you know what would be pretty
interesting is if during the
conversation between tormund and ed we
find out that they actually felt
something happened at Castle black
Lord Commander ed could say something
like you know what we did see the entire
walls start to shake or vibrate but at
the time we didn't know what the hell
was happening now this entire scene
doesn't have to be very long either
after a quick conversation we need to
see these men get on some horses and
start heading down the Kings Road right
to Winterfell if you remember back in
the very first season Jon left
Winterfell in the second episode and he
made it to the wall in that very same
episode they were travelling at a
reasonable pace but tormund barrack and
Ed and whoever else should be hauling
ass to get down there now I know it
probably shouldn't be wasting time
explaining any other traveling because
I'm sure the show will throw all of that
out the window but I want my breakdowns
to make sense by being somewhat
realistic now let's go down to
Winterfell where things should be
getting more interesting by this point
of the season I ended my last video by
having Jamie arrived just outside of
Winterfell gates while simultaneously
having brain send out the Ravens to go
spy on the night Kings movements if
brain does happen to spy on the night
king to track his movements which would
be very smart to know where he's at at
all times
bran needs to continuously relay that
information to Jon so he can
progressively pick up the intensity
around Winterfell what I mean by that is
soldiers should be on standby or even
getting into position in more and more
dragonglass getting crafted into useable
blades we should see a steady presence
of this kind of activity during every
single Sina winter fo at least until the
night King arrives let's start off the
Winterfell scenes by having Jamie reach
the gates with Bronn and his men since
Jamie will most likely be traveling with
such a large party they should be able
to see him coming from a distance
therefore Sansa
Daenerys Jon and whoever else should be
at the gates to meet him they will want
to know who the hell is approaching
their gates with an army although they
should be able to spot some of the
banners well before he reaches them as
we all know everyone in the north hates
the Lannisters but even more so they
despise the Kingslayer
what can make Jamie's arrival even worse
is the fact that he could be showing up
in the Northwest soldiers from House
Frey
you know the people responsible for
butchering their last
in the north Rob Sark along with his
mother Catelyn Stark but let us not
forget Jamie also tried to murder bran
Stark so when Jamie reaches the gates
[ __ ] just might pop off I'm really
hoping that Lord Glover and Yan Royce
are present during Jaime's arrival
because they are John's most vocal
supporters I can imagine them saying
something like re John you know what we
let [ __ ] slide when you brought the
wildlings into the north and we even let
[ __ ] slide when you brought Daenerys and
her dragons into the north but now
you've gone too far you want us to fight
alongside the Kingslayer who shows up at
your gates flying the Frey banners don't
be surprised when John ends up getting
his wig split or those cheeks busted
when he tries to go to sleep that night
shit's really gonna hit the fan when
Jamie reveals that Cersei lied about
sending their banners to help fight the
army of the Dead I have a pretty good
feeling that John might lose some
support during this episode you're on
Royce might take the Knights of the Vale
back to the Eyrie we already heard some
of the men say that they should go home
and wait out the storm
the Bolton's are defeated the war is
over winter has come if the Masters are
right it'll be the coldest one in a
thousand years we should ride home and
wait out the coming storms the war is
not over and I promised your friend the
true enemy won't wait out the storm
he brings the storm so when you combine
that with all of the drama I could
easily see some of the troops deciding
to abandon his cause but that's just a
guess I also imagine that Tyrion and
Barina Tarth will come to Jamie's
defense you should be able to cut the
tension with a knife
but since Jonathan Aerys already agreed
to call a truce while they fight the
night king people will just have to get
over the fact that the Kingslayer was
given permission to fight alongside of
them now I also think that in this
episode Daenerys might reveal to Jon
that she is pregnant with his child this
is something that Daenerys best say to
John in private before they go revealing
that information to everyone at this
point in time when tensions are already
so high maybe there can even be a scene
where they speak in one of the bedrooms
of the castle or down in the crypts of
Winterfell Daenerys could say something
along the lines of I haven't been
feeling too well so I went to see your
maester to see if there was anything he
could give me
but upon further inspection he says that
I am indeed pregnant this could be a
very emotional scene for Daenerys
because she has assumed that she could
never get pregnant again she has always
said the Dragons will be the only
children she'll ever have now we also
know what John has always said but I
couldn't do it because all I could think
was what if ACCA's her pregnant she had
a child another bastard named snow
it's a good life for a job he has said
he will never father a bastard which
could lead to John and Daenerys getting
married sometime next season but this is
something that doesn't have to happen
right away because they do have more
pressing issues at the moment I also
think that we need to get a pretty big
scene with brain stark during this
episode as well like I said the night
king will be arriving in Winterfell by
the third episode
therefore brain Sam Tyrion or whoever
needs to start finding some answers
inside of the weirwood net or those
books from the Citadel ASAP this would
be a good episode to start doing this
considering that the night king will be
here in the following episode
not to mention this would also give
enough time for all these characters to
start intermingling with one another by
now Sam could have started to look
through all the books he took from the
Citadel and if he had helped was someone
like Tyrion he could make sense of all
that information a hell of a lot faster
if brain doesn't figure out when and
where to look on his own then he's gonna
need someone to feed him that
information bran might have to go all
the way back in time to when the White
Walkers came for the first time which is
a story he's heard from old naen ever
since he was a little boy obviously the
White Walkers did not completely take
over Westeros during the first long
night otherwise none of these characters
would have even been born so he might
need to go back and see what happened
during the long night and see how it
ended what really caused the White
Walkers to flee back into the north can
they recreate whatever was done back
then if there truly was a legendary
figure like the last hero or azor Ahai
can that prophecy be fulfilled once
again which character from our current
story can take this legendary figures
place these are just some of the things
that brain can possibly find inside of
the weirwood net now I am assuming that
brain will see more than just this but
these are some of the things that we
have heard about since the beginning of
the story so I imagine they would come
into play to some extent by the end of
the story now what I think would be
really cool is as soon as brain comes
out of his vision of learning more about
the night King and hopefully how to stop
his advance this could transition right
into our final scene of the episode as
I've said before we should see the night
King attack a few castles before he
reaches Winterfell
this could keep the night King moving at
a reason
pace to allow all of our other
characters to get the Winterfell before
he arrives it would also allow brain a
little more time to figure out how to
stop him before it's too late
also if us as an audience get to see the
night King completely obliterating town
after town this will intensify the fear
of knowing what could happen when he
reaches Winterfell where most of our
beloved characters are located this
would also raise the stakes in Westeros
because what was always a threat just
lurking on the other side of the wall
has now become a reality as they
continually find out the night king is
smashing town after town as he works his
way down to the central location in the
north which is of course Winterfell we
need to see him getting much closer by
the end of this episode
perhaps we could even get a scene in
Winterfell where one of the characters
makes a comment about how the
temperature keeps getting lower and
lower with each passing night I think
that would be a really interesting way
of indicating how the night king is
getting closer and closer to Winterfell
but let me know what you think about
this episode don't forget to leave some
questions or comments down below make
sure you tune in for the next episode
because that will be the third episode
where [ __ ] is really gonna pop off I
want to thank everyone for watching
today's video
I really appreciate that as always and I
also want to thank everyone on patreon
for supporting the channel I hope you
all have a great day I will see you in
the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]